the jurogan experience when boxing came
along
boxing was my first love you know i
i got distracted by the music game
because of
i mean by boxing because of the music
game i always wanted to uh
be a boxer but it wasn't any gems in
fifth ward
you know so i always said to myself if i
ever make it
i want to build a boxing gym a
recreation center
in my hood and that's what i've done and
shortly after i'd done that i had an
opportunity to go in the gym and i
started watching the amateurs
and i just kind of fell in love with
boxing all over again
and which ultimately led me
i pray for a champion everything i tried
to accomplish
in life i always exercised prayer it
worked for me
so i prayed for a champion and
i set up a meeting with mike tyson in
las vegas
and i went to las vegas this had to be
99 or 2 000. so
you know i i knew a friend that knew
mike and mike
you know accepted the invitation because
he was familiar with my movement
where raphael i was concerned and i flew
out there
uh with my focus on mike and man i
walked into him sparring and i was like
you know i was on cloud nine because i
had never saw him you know in person
spawn it was always at a fight
and i walked in and he was throwing
leather with another heavyweight
and i was like star struck
and in the midst of watching this spawn
floyd mayweather came in the gym and
floyd you know
i didn't know who he was he kept coming
to me yo jay
yo jay oh man i know i know i know about
your group
you know he's calling groups out i'm
like oh okay thanks bro
thanks bro i'm zeroing back in on mike
boom boom boom flaw come over again yo
hey yo jay oj
man i know about this group here man and
and j if you want to do something late
on you know this my number i'll come
pick you up
i'm like all right brother okay focus on
mike i don't know who floyd is right
so afterwards you know me and mike go to
his house to have the meeting that i
came to have because
my objective was to become his manager
to be on his management team
and he and i met for hour he got his
ex-wife on the phone and
you know i was pretty much convinced i
was on the team after
the meeting and everything took place
and uh
you know hung with him all night the
next day
uh i tried to reach mike and i couldn't
reach mike
and i was left uh with flawed number and
i asked my friend i said who
who number is this number right here he
said oh that's floyd mayweather the 130
pound
champion so bam a red light went off in
my head because i prayed for a champion
long story short me and floyd was in
business together less than a week
that's how his manager you didn't even
know who he was i didn't know
no idea that was when he was pretty boy
floyd yeah that was before
money mayweather yeah he had a totally
different style back then too
he was much more aggressive went for the
knockout war
yeah well i think he used his legs a lot
more than but if he saw the opportunity
he definitely went in for the kill
but you know his whole image was
different before
i came about well he had a lot of hand
problems
right like he's had several hand breaks
yeah
well i don't know about a break but i
know uh we eventually had to get a
specialist to wrap
his hands because you know he would hurt
him a lot
yeah and do you think that affected his
style is that like because he developed
a very defensive style
as he got older um i think that's a part
of uh
confidence i think that's a part of
evolving as a fighter
you know in the beginning i think floyd
used his legs
much more but as he evolved with
experience he got comfortable
you know with shoulder roll and defense
yeah greatest defense of all time oh man
of all time yeah i agree i had my friend
andrew schultz on here yesterday we were
talking about it we're like he
might have got hit hard four times in
his career
which is insane 50-0 and got
tagged four times which is unthinkable
no he's
amazing but his work ethic is amazing
you know the guy got to work
you know i've had opportunity to like
witness
a lot of fighters work epic andre wards
and floyd mayweather work ethic is
unlike any fight i ever saw yeah you
don't get there without it
exactly because there's so many talented
people there's so many athletic people
there's so many fierce dudes
but to be a champion yeah you need
everything
you need gifts you need athletic gifts
you need a sharp mind
you need a passion for the technical
aspects of the game
but you got to have that ethic if you
don't have that work ethic you don't
you never keep it going you you always
fall short of your expectations and
without naming any names
we all know those champions that could
have been
great but they got fat in between
camps and they just never trained as
hard as they should have and
i mean some of the all-time greats
suffered from it like roberto duran
after he
beat sugar a leonard yeah he and and
sugar ray knew it
capitalized on it and forced a quick
rematch
when he knew that duran was fat and
durant is partying and drinking and yeah
a guy like floyd mayweather never did
that no
never got out of shape man he would you
know floyd was the type of fighter that
would party with
everybody but no drinking no smoking
you sit back and watch and observe the
whole movement
i remember watching a video of him
leaving a club in vegas it showed him at
the club
hanging out with everybody leaving the
club at two in the morning running
oh yeah we used to do that all the time
yeah regular pants on
we would watch fights together and
right after the fight he was ready to
run yo jay yo
ain't nobody gonna catch me slipping the
only way they can beat you is catch you
out of shape
they ain't gonna catch me slipping take
off running down the strip
it's amazing and having his brother
or having uh having his uncle roger and
having his father
you know two world-class fighters and
having
grown up seeing these guys seeing his
his
uncle when roger mayweather was a
champion
he had a vicious style he was
you know his right hand was a thing of
beauty i mean
people forgot like i was watching some
roger mayweather fights the other day
and to have his father a guy who you
know gave sugar ray leonard a hell of a
fight
there's so much talent and so much
knowledge and understanding of boxing in
that family
to grow up with that and to have that
mindset like floyd has where he's
observing and watching everything
that dude just absorbed everything
oh yeah and not only watching he had to
spoil roger
so you talking about you know having to
learn how to protect yourself against
the best
yeah as a kid so you know he had access
to a lot of power and evidently
you know there's no doubt about it it
benefited him in a major way
when you met floyd he was the 130 pound
champion
and did you just immediately started
working with him
uh yeah but it was a process and it was
uh
it wasn't easy because i came into a
situation where
his father and his uncle was his manager
and
i wasn't embraced uh you know with love
you know because they kind of felt like
i was
imposing on a situation he had a 12
million dollar contract on the table
at the time i came in that everybody
wanted him to sign
and uh floyd called the contract a slave
contract
before i came but they blamed me
for him calling the contract a slave
contract so
what was the uh provisions in the
contract that he didn't like
well he just thought 12 million wasn't
enough
you know what i mean and you know
ultimately
i had to go in and do some damage
control
and one of the things that i told him
when you know when i met him i said i
can't make this better
i don't want to eat off of your 12
million that i already been
offered to you so i had opportunity to
have a meeting with
said abraham you know at the time was
the uh
the president of uh hbo and
i pretty much just asked the guy you
know how
could we get around this 12 million
dollar contract
how can i uh make this a bigger contract
and
at the time he told me about the fighter
named diego corrales
he's like you know if you all would be
willing to fight diego corrales
then this could jump up to 35 million or
so if y'all was able to beat diego
corrales and uh
you know that was interesting to me you
know i went home and done some due
diligence
on diego corrales at the time and at
that particular time
diego had uh jumped on his ex-wife
and kind of beat up he had charges
you know uh kind of done her pretty bad
but bad to the extent where he was
facing jail time
and and i saw that and i went back to
florida i said floyd
i said it's a perfect time to fight
diego corrales i said i even have a
marketing tool we can whoop him for
every battle woman in the united states
of america
so he heard me out but he wasn't
embracing it no no
no no no no jay it ain't time to do that
right now
no no no no so he didn't want to fight
diego because diego skill set
well you know i don't want to say floyd
was scared but at the time
you know everybody thought diego could
beat floyd he was like 30 and over 29
knockouts
diego was a wild man yeah diego was he
was a knockout artist
and he just felt like it wasn't the time
i talked to him for like four hours
and couldn't convince him so i decided
to go home
and i went home about six in the morning
and i woke up
about 11 in the morning with a message
from him
yo yo jay i hired you you know as my
manager
and uh if you think i should fight him
i'll fight him so
it was then where you know i was
celebrating i'm like whoa
we finna get diego so i called the
people
at hbo and they told me they didn't have
a date they wouldn't have a date
to uh next year or something like that
and it was then i decided to use uh
some of my record label uh talents
you know i had to build my record
company without having video
without having radio you know just
pulling publicity stunts
so i told florida so here's what we're
going to do
uh lennox lewis and david tour was
fighting at the
at the mandalay bay i say during the
press conference
i'm hearing diego supposed to come to
that fight i say during the press
conference
we're gonna surround diego my head of
home is to surround diego
and i want you to come and just push him
and
and we're gonna stop the fight right but
it's not gonna ain't gonna be no free
fight but
you go and get your push in on and we're
going to stop it we're going to steal
the show that was my
objective and uh that came to fruition
you know we went and stole the show at
the press conference
that was saturday night sunday we was on
the front page of the uh
las vegas time and you know monday or
tuesday i called them and they said oh
we got a date for you
i love that you're telling me this
because i always wonder i always wonder
when i see those kind of altercations
how many of those are coordinated
by a wise man who understands publicity
quite a few i would say why wouldn't you
yeah why wouldn't you you know it's
marketing
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience on spotify
you can listen to the jre in the
background while using other apps and
can download episodes to save on data
cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience